charlie bomb wiwa tarde pero genial
por tu propio juego digo que no
me simplifico para montar un deo urbano
menor también ha sido premiado por la
Pentágono lombardo fue y a la novia de
Magliana ahora sí de bienes tardíos
hora de washington que usaron te dicen
libros sin escala una palabra bardy e
el silbido del éxtasis áspero la brazada
tambien se arreglaron un punto de frente
al entrara quien siria donde si contra juan
de un juan sigue las armas del pentágono
personal militar como el pentágono y
Estoy en reacción a estos ataques y del
kin se de febrero y norte de irak e
Los negros del aeropuerto pegados a las paredes estaban
conocí a san filipino aliano en un
strauss liosis a colisión probado en
noticias e irak también resultan útiles
barrios y US según oficinas
alese de la inteligencia del pentagono si
ataques y este el kin se de febrero
contra el último fue una audiencia
espen irak era un grupo jamal all us e
lowes guardianes de la sangría
precisamente los ataques se sienten lejos
nuez fueron respuesta fue que en el
reinas y tierra